Rangkaian neural adalah satu kelas algoritma pembelajaran mesin yang hebat
dan ia datang dalam pelbagai jenis
tak mungkin nak bagi perhatian yang cukup kepada rangkaian neural
dalam video pengenalan
macam ni di sini kita hanya akan kenal pasti beberapa komponen utama
sebuah rangkaian neural dan aliran kerja keseluruhannya
supaya kita boleh faham macam mana pengkomputeran kuantum boleh menyumbang
rangkaian neural adalah graf neuron yang saling berhubung
satu neuron pada dasarnya cuma sesuatu yang menyimpan nombor
dan nombor tu selalu dipanggil pengaktifan, sejauh mana
neuron tu hidup atau mati
neuron-neuron disusun dalam beberapa lapisan
dan lapisan pertama adalah lapisan input
dan yang terakhir adalah lapisan output
di antara tu ada lapisan yang digunakan dalam pemprosesan yang dipanggil
lapisan tersembunyi; pengaktifan
lapisan input dimuatkan terus dari data yang nak dianalisis
seperti pelarasan piksel dalam sebuah gambar
pengaktifan lapisan tersembunyi seterusnya ditentukan
oleh neuron-neuron dalam lapisan input
dan oleh pemberat yang disimbolkan dengan garis yang menghubungkan semua neuron
dalam lapisan input ke semua neuron dalam
lapisan seterusnya; dengan kata lain kita tentukan pengaktifan
satu neuron dalam lapisan tersembunyi
dengan jumlah berpemberat semua
pengaktifan input; kita boleh
juga tambah bias, iaitu anjakan
mungkin kita nak aktifkan satu neuron
dalam lapisan tersembunyi bukan sekadar kalau jumlah berpemberat tu
positif, tapi hanya kalau ia melebihi ambang yang besar
lepas tu kita selalu guna fungsi kompleks untuk dapat pengaktifan
antara sifar dan satu, macam tangen hiperbolik
atau kadang-kadang berbeza, iaitu
unit linear rektifikasi; kau tak perlu risau
sangat pasal benda ni sekarang; yang
penting untuk diperhatikan tentang fungsi-fungsi ni
adalah ia tak linear
supaya rangkaian secara keseluruhannya mengandungi kedua-dua komponen linear
dan bukan linear
jumlah berpemberat pengaktifan yang sama, kali ni
bermula dengan pengaktifan
lapisan tersembunyi pertama dalam pemberat baru
diteruskan ke lapisan tersembunyi seterusnya
ini berterusan hingga ke lapisan akhir iaitu output
lapisan output mempunyai neuron yang sepadan dengan
kategori dan pengaktifan memberitahu kita
seberapa pasti rangkaian tu tentang pengelasan
jadi kategori output dalam analisis imej mungkin adalah
anjing, kucing, hamster dan sebagainya
dan pengaktifan sebanyak 0.95 pada
neuron anjing menunjukkan tahap keyakinan yang tinggi bahawa
gambar tu adalah gambar anjing; kau mungkin mulakan rangkaian neural kau
dengan set pemberat yang rawak
dan bias atau dari konfigurasi permulaan yang munasabah yang diketahui
tapi kemudian idea dia adalah untuk semak
seberapa bagus rangkaian neural kau mengklasifikasikan benda
dan memperbaikinya; kita guna fungsi kos untuk huraikan
macam mana rangkaian neural kita tersasar dari
pengelasan yang betul; ini melibatkan pengambilan
perbezaan antara nilai sebenar sebuah gambar
contohnya nilai satu pada neuron
untuk anjing dan sifar pada semua neuron output lain
dan nilai yang diramalkan
kita jumlahkan semua kategori
jadi kita pantau bukan sahaja sama ada kategori yang betul
paling aktif tapi kita boleh
juga pantau kalau pengaktifan yang salah dikurangkan
dalam jumlah semua contoh dalam set latihan kita
dan dapat kos; lepas tu kita
ubah parameter macam pemberat dalam setiap lapisan
antara semua neuron dan bias pada semua lapisan
rutin pengoptimuman klasik digunakan
untuk mencari minimum tempatan dalam fungsi kos
kalau tak ada apa yang dilakukan untuk mengurangkan kerumitan ni
kau boleh bayangkan betapa
astronomikalnya ruang parameter yang kita dah set up ni
bayangkan satu rangkaian neural yang direka untuk menganalisis imej dengan
hanya seribu piksel; rangkaian neural ni mungkin ada seribu
neuron input, cuma satu lapisan tersembunyi
dan output binari macam kucing atau anjing
ini adalah kes yang paling mudah sekali
dan masih bersamaan dengan seribu kali seribu
atau sejuta pemberat antara lapisan input dan tersembunyi
dan dua ribu lagi antara
lapisan tersembunyi dan output
mungkin juga ada seribu atau
lebih bias; jadi rangkaian neural mudah ni bersamaan dengan
lebih dari sejuta parameter; memang la, kalau nak adil
algoritma moden biasanya memang buat penyederhanaan
dalam rangkaian neural klasik
dan ada bidang-bidang keseluruhan yang didedikasikan untuk membuat penimalan ni
boleh dilakukan dan bahkan cekap
tapi hakikatnya ini adalah masalah yang sangat
berdimensi tinggi
dan melatih rangkaian neural
boleh memakan masa yang sangat lama
dan mahal; rangkaian neural kuantum atau QNN
berfungsi dengan pertama sekali memuatkan data input
kemudian menerapkan quantum circuits
yang sepadan dengan pemberat antara lapisan
dan akhirnya satu lapisan pengukuran
beberapa perkara penting tentang ni; data
pemuatan dan pemberat adalah operasi linear
tapi pengukuran adalah bukan linear
jadi seperti dalam rangkaian neural klasik kita ada
kedua-dua komponen linear dan bukan linear
juga, circuit pemberat
masih ada parameter variasi
jadi masih ada penimalan klasik yang perlu dijalankan
memang la ini cuma mencalar permukaan rangkaian neural kuantum
tapi kami harap kau terus belajar tentang aplikasi
rangkaian neural kuantum
dan aplikasi pembelajaran mesin kuantum lain
bersama IBM Quantum